Hey I mean house go impress my name's
Peter path I challenge you brothers last
week to do my intro in a funny and
creative way these are their results
let's go and also welcome to Friday's
River okay someone's sleeping 2056 that
supposed to be me my name is boots hey
daddy hey no no no you got it should
have stopped after the brofist you know
I will be dead long before I look like
that alright so good
Bravo you win you win the competition we
found the winner right there
hands go frenzy they got my paintings
how do they get such high resolution hey
Edgar does that I don't do that that was
cool
I'm really impressed by these so far
except the toothbrush one whatever how's
it going guys my name Mogambo is a cutie
pie you the pilot for Z while they
Kosovo's Air Force One
I did in my hand go to the moon that was
awesome ha ha how does a killer dress
Lenny me hey Felix means fence got into
so bro home day three we thought three
fast what gender mother 1913 pizza
polygamy good video journalist migrant
another potential Phoenix is way jovial
and retirement was trained in its Goku
become a lease on a persona so me make
money he answers 28 it was that please
any another lot
what the [ __ ] okay so he was rapping in
Swedish even though he was Korean and
American uh Swedish was pretty good that
was awesome
he also does plenty cool bit what the
[ __ ] is going on here house gum resumes
that's when you name might when my mom
gave birth to me she was like I will
name him she was actually just possessed
by Satan look how nice I became sorry I
love these so far that I've done names
beauty oh good
Peter pop he's an awesome guy I am
winning watch fire Peter pop
duh hey that's hardcore man this guy is
gonna be the next to puck let me just
say that right now someone signed this
guy right now this is the best nice
green screen dude how's it going bros my
name six hours spent in editing you did
it good job
nice Fodor don't just spit out of me I
was gonna compliment your fedora carrot
what is he spitting out I didn't see you
there
what do you spit what the [ __ ] you to me
Oh Joey cut this brofist
oh don't punch don't touch me please
ah how's it going bros my name is Oh
finished right let's go bros my name is
but but there's 30 seconds left
producer 15 secondly participants
uh-huh
never seen such good content to credit
ratio what is that video is the video is
two seconds but the credit is 28 seconds
those two seconds per quality Allah
really enjoy the credits to actually has
a good rose my name is bathtub okay
skid my name is hey did the arm thing up
and the Oscars doing and you say I need
to get her life oh my god I gotta click
on this hey guys hi so what I'm she
looks happy about oh sorry
hey we got music here
you can call me senpai
ah
oh my back up I'm fine
what's the joke how's it going boys
my name is cutie pie house
ah
stay cool bros is it over how it's going
good
holy [ __ ] whoa hey that was short but
awesome I have the same Gundam
[ __ ] that's adorable
hahaha oh my god
reputed by IMX are a rope beautifies
here I'm his biggest fan this is just
for a contest with Oh what do you know
you're just in my head me Felix oh my
god no please
yes what the [ __ ] is going on that's
how's it going bros my name is
the [ __ ] did I just watch I don't I
always wanted a table flip like that
why is her moustached I don't have a lot
of questions I'm just getting more and
more weirded out how's it going out well
well then well then well then my name is
buta okay I think I think we took one
step too far in right now
how's it going climb pros like pros my
name is that his house I don't how's it
going bros my name is it's a boy ha ha
ha don't sample my videos and make me
weird how's it going bros whoa what the
[ __ ] that I just watch that's awesome
hey how's it going my name is Pierre
biggest hey that's cool
Oh
I
that's cool can I try that it's like
weird if I try that okay stay awesome
did I do that right
press breakfast that's cool house
compress my name's Ben
oh my you're so cute how's gum fries
money whoa but holy [ __ ] I look badass
dude my hands are so big look at that
that's [ __ ] cool Oh
oh my gosh Toula song the character sing
play it backwards
he's gave me a help I see my speed he's
a game and help us a cry for help
what the [ __ ] was that oh man that was
awesome
I'm gonna sub to that channel that was
[ __ ] awesome Peter by his cancer well
thank you
Bulger's under stop that hit rules how's
it going my name's PewDiePie yet no that
was yes yes can we watch that again cuz
I didn't really catch up so we got hit
rules how's it going my name's PewDiePie
yes how's gamers my nose
why the [ __ ] would you do that you know
what that is that's pretty good use of
the back I don't [ __ ] dish oh that's
[ __ ] cold
oh he's drinking all these fans no way
to troll my fans dude ha ha ha all right
that was all the submissions thank you
both so much for doing this I had a lot
of fun reviewing them it was really cool
I love doing these kind of things with
you bros where we interact and make
videos together in a sense so I thought
we're gonna do that again for next week
so I'm announcing another competition
right here right now basically I
recorded myself in front of a green
screen doing a bunch of weird [ __ ] so I
want you brothers to edit a video out of
all this whatever you can make and
submit it for next week's fries with
Pitt apply winner will win nothing but
glory do it if that sounds interesting
check out the link in the description I
can't wait to see where your boys are
gonna do with these videos that's it for
me for now think it was so much for
watching and as always
brofist Oh
what the [ __ ] was that Jesus Christ how
do you even make a sound like that what
is that
you sound like you're swallowing
yourself